everywhere we go today it's likely
there's a camera filming us critics say
such surveillance has gotten out of hand
Berlin's museum of communication is
currently hosting a special exhibit
about the state's omnipresent
collections of data it's called out of
control living in a world under
surveillance from the secret police
telephone surveillance centers and
communist East Germany to monitoring
devices in the West the exhibit is a
trip through history that gives visitors
pause for thought a lot can you have no
control over who's watching him immersed
in money my private sphere is extremely
important to me I don't want someone
listening into my bedroom it seems to me
it doesn't give me the chills yet but it
could if things go on like this instead
I surveyed the gift researchers at the
University in the northern German city
of Hilda's Heim want to put a stop to
the explosion of surveillance and are
working on a safer computer they've
developed a so called associative
machine it's an alternative to
conventional computer technology and its
creators are hoping it will spark a
revolution industry is gazing caused by
there's a huge difference a conventional
computer as a central processor that
does everything you should imagine the
associative machine is something like a
human brain you have connections that
are like nerve tracts and circuits that
are like synapses you also have neurons
that receive all the information and
decide whether to transmit it further
we've demonstrated that this machine
performs better than a conventional
computer that's why I want to build it
doesn't even believe in bone
hans-joachim Benson and his colleagues
have been working on the ultra complex
system for 30 years the computer codes
are deposited in a matrix instead of
under memory addresses that would
present a challenge for intelligence
agencies like the NSA
their surveillance programs focus on
memory addresses and would be useless
against the associative machine like a
living from a doorknob thereafter
information like what in a written
document or what's in my email database
if I set up a database here it's non
transparent as is the sequence of
individual textural elements or email
content it's difficult to reconstruct
it's way beyond the capabilities of
conventional technology a surveillance
proof computer is still a long way off
at present the technology is used only
in software for example for a robotic
vehicle capable of learning researchers
now want to build the hardware and
several investors are ready to stump up
the cash what they need is a company to
turn the blueprints into functional
machinery it's fitting concrete for the
construction of the machine it's
important to convince any interested
company that we figured out all the
individual parts that would be the basis
to allow our partner to start talking to
experts and learn what has to be done
blame it on socom or does it help to
land a schematic lien the researchers
are convinced the project has enormous
potential their aim is to build an
associative computer ready for mass
production within the next few years the
students working on it are very excited
don't forget is my new bag or my host my
work leads to the creation of something
that lasts is might sound a bit
exaggerated but I hope I'm helping to
lay the foundation that revolutionizes
data security during the darkest of
heart the first steps have been taken
and who knows maybe someday the hill
design computer will be part of an
exhibit in Berlin about how computer
surveillance was ultimately curtailed